You will recall that the second form of interoperability
provides a structure that contained the elements,
so that the receiving system knows what each element represents,
even though it may have no semantic understanding of its contents.
A common example is electronic lab reporting
results back to the provider who ordered a test.
Earlier, we mentioned HL7's Messaging Standard that dates from the 1980s.
The version 2 standard, you see,
here is based on edX 12 technology from that era.
The two lines in red are test results.
You can see that other lines may contain only a text message.
So this is not entirely a tightly structured standard.
With some study, you should be able to figure out
the contents of most of the fields in this message.
You should also agree that it is not nearly as human
readable as an XML formatted message.
The newer v3 HL7 Messaging Standard uses XML.
But v2 is baked into many existing systems,
and according to the CDC,
and despite its age in 2013,
90% of electronic lab reporting consisted of HL7
compliant messages using various versions of the v2 Messaging Standard..